you might think evolution takes a long
time and it often does
but in today's cities plants animals and
microbes are all under immense pressure
to survive and thrive
researchers combed through years of data
and discovered some of the genetic
changes wrought by high-rises extensive
roads and close association with people
data shows that urban areas chances of
mutation correlate with the amount of
pollution herring gulls and industrial
steel towns experience greater rates of
mutation than in rural or non industrial
areas genetic drift where allele
frequency changes are driven by chance
is found in small and isolated
populations such conditions are now
being created by cities where
fragmentation and isolation is created
through urban development in other words
certain traits may become more or less
common by chance
rather than selection at least initially
salamander populations in New York City
Montreal and Oviedo Spain each had lower
levels of genetic diversity in
populations and more rural areas this
decrease in diversity is leading to
increased differences between
populations not only between rural areas
put urban ones as well decreased genetic
diversity can have negative impacts for
example extreme bottleneck events reduce
the potential for species to adapt to
changing conditions and can lead to
inbreeding Bobcats living in Los Angeles
are currently experiencing a bottleneck
due to urban development fragmenting the
population a chemical exposure from prey
pesticides local adaptation is common it
often helps an organism deal with its
changing environment
it appears such local adaptation is
occurring with cities as well for
example bedbug populations across the
u.s. show genetic differences between
cities finally what can we actually see
in physical adaptations in Tucson
Arizona urban house hitches have adapted
to their sunflower seen heavy bird
feeder based diet their beaks are longer
and wider than the rural cousins
in Montpellier France Holy Hawks beard
plants are producing more seats that
dispersed closer to the parent plant due
to the lack of optimal soil around the
city ultimately it's important to be
sure that as urban areas expand they do
so in a way that's conducive to life
that dwells within them human or
otherwise
[Music]
[Music]